foreign
foreign
thank you
Norway are now establishing a message
and our Center to enhance the Norwegian
dower if you donate to the schools you
will ensure Allah reap the rewards of
thousands of Muslims coming back to
Islam and many of those who become
Dwight and invite Islam so click the
link and donate now and share the video
for extra Rewards
foreign
what's going on guys hey man how's it
going it's going good good
and to all the viewers salaam alaikum
welcome back to the three Muslims
probably by the end of this podcast the
five Muslims when I was not just playing
um real quick we started this podcast
two years ago with the sole purpose of
spreading Islam exposing the truth about
the misconceptions that the world is
throwing about Islam my name is brother
Rami over here and that's brother anho
amazing it's great to meet you guys
likewise likewise
all right Rami bro do you want to take
over
I mean it's it's all for a game we're
all here just to chat right
uh sunny and Elena we spoke you know a
few minutes before this is a pleasure uh
we want to do this for a little while
now
um and I asked this before but I want to
ask it again just so the viewers you
know can uh can hear the answer as well
did you guys know that your videos
discussing educate we're gonna blow up
the way that they did
so with the initial videos I kind of
made those intentionally to go viral
with the entertain ones I was like
Andrew Kate is the most trending thing
and Mom reacts as like a cheat code to
going viral I kind of just put those two
together it was a business decision on
his part yeah it was definitely
calculated and then I'd use like
specific algorithm stuff I know behind
the scenes marketed on Tick Tock so it
definitely blew up more than I thought
but it got a you know yeah I didn't
think that I didn't think that me being
as part of the channel would really be
as big of a thing as it is and uh it's
turning into something that's really fun
for us and a really fun way for us to
spend time together and these are the
conversations we have anyway so for you
know him to be able to use it in
business it must be able to have a good
time is awesome but yeah it's kind of
this is not a path I I thought I was
going to be on if you would have told me
I was going to be on this path earlier
this year I would oh making YouTube
videos yeah I know yeah it's a cool path
I mean you're on it too and you guys are
doing really well
and you know how does have did you
expect this yourselves
it's funny because if I had mentioned in
the beginning we started this Channel
with the sole purpose of if we can just
help one person then that's enough for
us so we I mean we had our hopes but me
personally I never expected to see like
a hundred thousand which we're about to
hit alhamdulillah you know I was we just
had the goal of we want to help people
we want to guide people to Islam we want
to speak the truth and dispel any
misconceptions that are out there fight
on hobo you want to add to that
no I mean you you said it you said it
perfectly bro
it's a really cool Mission you know as a
as a Christian and you've seen some of
our videos where I've been talking about
how my
level of Christianity has stepped up
over the past year or so and you know it
was like in and out my whole life but
I've you know come to it in a whole
different way this year and so one of
the things I understand that my job as a
disciple is to be a fisher of men
that's how it was put to you know
Jesus's disciples in in the in the Bible
and you're doing that and you're you
know
not fishing for Jesus of course but
um I I really think that whether I catch
some fish or you catch some fish I think
we're making we can make the world a
better place by bringing people closer
to God either way is going to be better
so it's very cool that that's your whole
point I love it absolutely absolutely
and that doesn't mean a lot and you know
what's actually it's funny because from
our perspective we would say that we are
actually also fulfilling the you know
fishing for Jesus kind of mission
because we believe that Jesus called
people to worship one God alone and to
enjoin good and forbid evil and I don't
know maybe it's a little early to pull
this out the brothers know what I'm
about to pull out but I have this uh
this book here it's called the five
gospels and um long story short they put
in Gray letters things Jesus probably
didn't say black letters things he
didn't say and then you see like the
pink down here these are things Jesus
probably did say and when I was going
through it
I found a lot of Jesus's most beautiful
messages are the ones that the scholars
who put this together agree he probably
said this like he almost definitely said
this you know for example love thy
enemies isn't like red bold letters so
messages like that are the ones that
Muslims resonate with very very kindly
and it's kind of that understanding of
Jesus that we want to portray to the
world but for Elena for you I know that
you mentioned recently you kind of came
back to it and sunny I know that you
mentioned that you're interested in
Islam because you know recently educate
accepted Islam and that kind of gazed
your interest so how are you both with
you know Christianity Islam and
spirituality
I mean I can go first I've never like
I've grown up Christian but I've never
been too big into church myself like
I've just never really resonated with it
you know and my my view on Islam has
always been very like Americanized if if
you know what I mean like I'm not
surrounded by Muslims growing up you
know I could only name like a couple
handful that I went to school with or
something like that so I never really
knew about the religion like even for
the longest time when I would think
about it it's like in my mind I wouldn't
have ever thought Jesus would be the
most mentioned Prophet inside of the
Quran like I I think it's like a
completely different religion like if I
think of like Hinduism and it has like
elephant like I have no idea what's what
was really going on inside you know what
I mean yeah and seeing you know how many
similarities there are inside the
religions especially with like core
beliefs has definitely changed my mind
to it a ton over the last few months you
know absolutely I I agree so yeah again
we were we're taught everything we need
to know about Islam through
um the media with a political slant that
talks taught you know we learned about
Islam through learning about
terrorist political organizations who
happen to also
be Muslim right and and it all just
becomes one thing in the news you know
and one of our big things is in all of
our videos is we tell everybody don't
believe what you see in the news look
deeper look deeper go ask questions get
more opinions do your own research and
you know so for us it you know we're
putting our money where our mouth is by
really researching Islam and and I and
I'm glad that we're doing that and for
me this this you know my Christian path
without getting into it because it's
been a long life you know all of it I
don't want to bore you to death but
God was always just on a throne in the
sky and very distant and that for is
what Catholicism did for me and you know
I've I've taken part more in um actual
Bible study and being more into the
Baptist uh sect of Christianity which is
you know really more biblical teachings
and Mission work and I'm not doing any
Mission work yet but like that's what
they do they really reach out into the
community so I have now a totally
different relationship with God and with
Jesus and it's so much more awesome and
real for me so he hasn't had that
experience yet you know we're just I'm
just bringing him into it because he was
raised Catholic he was raised with God
on the throne scary out there not really
in your heart and where Islam comes in
for me is I'm particularly fascinated
with the study of it now and seeing the
commonalities that's where I'm at right
now because I'm digging deeper and
deeper into the Old and New Testament
and really starting to learn for the
first time in my life in a way that's
meaningful
and I'm you know what I learned from all
these videos and all these conversations
is where the Common Ground we have and I
think that that's so awesome that to me
is like so beautiful that we have so
much common ground and I think that's a
message that we need to spread
absolutely absolutely there's a question
that just comes straight to my mind if
you guys don't mind me asking her but
did you know before at least let's say
before you started you know looking into
Islam a little bit more that it was also
an abrahamic faith
nope
I didn't know I don't even have a long
answer on that one just no
okay yeah yeah I mean there's a lot I
don't know there's still a ton I don't I
mean I I've only scratched the surface
on Christianity I went to 12 years of
Catholic school and I feel like a new
Christian so so I'm learning both of
these uh both of these religions in
parallel
it is how it feels
more I know more about Christianity just
because I did pick up something in all
those years but in in a really deeper
biblical scholarly way this is a whole
new world for me so
you said that you grew up
learning Catholicism correct yes okay
so it's actually amazing that you're
saying what you're saying that you're
doing what you're doing you know may God
bless you because you you truly seem
sincere in you know what you're saying
you're still in everything and I'm sure
there's there's way more to your story
because you only
Swatch
but in Islam like we're actually told to
look for the answers to read for
ourselves and we're told to not not just
blindly follow what those before us
are following so like our parents our
family in general we're told to actually
just like look for the answers yourself
because if you're sincere uh God will
show you everything
yeah so I think I think it's it's real
beautiful that they y'all are on this
path
thank you it is for me it's I mean it's
every day there's I'm I'm reading
uh
about Christianity or studying it I'm
watching videos I watch more Christian
just entertainment than I used to
and it's it's life-changing to wake up
in the morning and open a book about you
know a book about the Bible or read a
Bible verse on an app or something then
to wake up and think about the um you
know serial killer documentary that I
watched the night before which was you
know spent years doing and it was
entertaining but where did it really
what did it have an impact on my life a
positive impact no no it doesn't it's
just empty entertainment yeah I don't
think I'm never going to watch that
again because hey you know we need dumb
entertainment sometimes but the priority
in my life is completely shifted and it
feels so
good yeah right it sounds like you guys
can
relate to that yeah yeah so I have a
question as well like I'm sorry I'm like
I'm taking it for you but um you said
that you had a shift
and in this shift that's when you
started to uh
started becoming more spiritual and you
started uh researching more
um devoting yourself more when would you
say that this [ __ ] happened and why
would you say that this shift happened
ah
it happened at a couple of different
points in my life
um where I felt like I kept going back
to the church and I would go back and I
would go every week for a few months and
then it just wasn't
connecting right but there were other
moments maybe at a retreat a spiritual
retreat with my school one of my schools
where I really felt something special
but then it went away and it just I
always knew it was there and then I
would forget and just get caught up in
life again because it never really
plugged all the way in right so
um
about a year ago now or so I started why
I came across
um this TV show called The Chosen
have you guys heard of it
oh gosh it's awesome okay so I'm gonna
go on a chosen commercial now so the
chosen is a fully crowdfunded uh show
about the about basically it's about
Jesus when he hit the scene as an adult
so it brings into Play Jesus how he
found his disciples who he chose uh the
people the the Pharisees in the Jewish
Community who were like who is this guy
you know he's a charlatan he's a
sorcerer he's nonsense he's pretending
to be saying he's God you know
um they were saying he was a blasphemer
and then you had the Romans and all the
politics and they were not happy with
him either and it does a really good job
of bringing the Bible to life and
bringing these characters to life uh you
should watch it just for entertainment
I'm not trying to convert you because I
know that's not an option and but it is
but it is it is entertaining and the
characters are really human and the
problems they have and the personalities
they have in the conflicts and they're
you know it's not like anything I had
ever seen and it took it down to this
really amazing place for me where it
just hit me so hard the type of person
he was and how he and how he chose the
people around him and how he loved
everyone
you know and and taught them to love
each other you know he brought in the
tax collector Matthew was a tax
collector and the Jews hated him because
they were he was you know he was a Jew
who worked for the Romans who was
ruining their lives with overburdening
them with taxes never giving them a
break and he brought them in and taught
them to love each other and that's
that's something that is an example of
wow what I really wish we could see
leaders doing today so that was that
opened the door for me and all of a
sudden not only did I binge watch this
show season three just came out this
week
um I started to really look into look
into Judaism and looking into
understanding the the Old Testament more
in a way that I never had
and all of a sudden I'm realizing that
the Bible has every single answer I
could ever need if I have a problem like
I have Googled things like what did
Jesus say about annoying people like
when I'm being human and and I I'm like
ready to flip out on somebody I'm like
maybe there's something in the Bible
that can help me to be more patient and
kind and there is no matter what you ask
it's in there and that's kind of crazy
and the things we've learned about the
Quran like all the science predictions
that Muhammad you know put you know told
and were eventually put down on paper it
it's wild you know how these things all
the answers are there money love
relationships business
um just you name it sickness you name it
it's all in there and for me it's just
opened up this whole world and I just
signed up I haven't even told you yet
but I just signed up to take the um
there's a seminary course
at the church that I just joined and it
starts at the end of January and it's a
four semester course that I could take
for credit or I can just audit I'm just
auditing it I don't need to be an
official so you know I don't need to be
official Theologian I don't need a
degree I just want it for myself because
I'm just fascinated now and then so
that's where it just happened and I'm
just I I'm never turning back
because nothing no no romantic partner
or no personal success no travel
experience nothing ever
can fulfill the way this does and
nothing is so consistent can stay
everything else is just retail therapy
um
absolutely should I answer your question
I just rambled up you know it was all
over it but it got the question oh yeah
that's how I talk all over the place
yeah sorry
so okay so with that being said
this means that you've you've kind of
like looked into the Torah in your days
and
and you looked into a little bit of the
Quran in Islam and you know you're now
understanding that this is like these
are the abrahamic faiths
and um the base of it all
it's uh it's the same message it's a
worship on God and be a good person
all right so with this being said like
with the the studying that you've done
so far with the the Torah like what have
you concluded with the little bit that
you've done with the Torah so far so
um really the Old Testament that I have
been learning
um
you know I'm just learning like a lot of
historical things first of all a lot of
facts that are that that add up well I'm
learning um
that Jesus came to the scene and he
would he was and it wasn't called the
Old Testament at the time but he was an
Old Testament scholar
um he and he came in and broke some
rules
and you know really change things that
they expected the Messiah to be a
warrior to break them free from their
oppressors and he wasn't
he was a lamb
and that was it wasn't what they
expected and and those are all lessons
um I feel a little I feel a little uh on
the spot and uneducated right now I wish
I had a better answer but I'm sure I'll
think of something
we're just having a conversation yeah
yeah
because I'm still just learning um and I
and I've learned a lot more about you
know their just religious practices of
you know the Friday night Shabbat dinner
and how special that is and why it's so
special and I really love it I'm loving
their Traditions more than I ever did
and I grew up in Brooklyn so like I had
a ton of Jewish friends like we were I
grew up in an Italian and Jewish
neighborhood so we you know we just
always mixed and you too I mean really
you've always all have a dad's friends
are Jewish and yeah you know that's
something that we're just very similar
you know and Italians and Jews Like
grandmothers are really being onto guilt
like we have a lot in common you know
Fiji you gotta eat more and you got to
feel guilty about everything that's what
we do so
um but learning on a more spiritual
level makes me appreciate them more you
know and of course
so
with that being said what are you guys
what do you both yours what are your
thoughts on uh Moses peace be upon him
Moses uh my understanding is you know he
was a a very important Prophet
um I know Moses David and Jesus had what
do they call that Alliance there was
like an alliance between the three of
them that they they had a name for it
they were real they were they got
together at some point this is so
ignorant you're talking about you're
talking about uh Moses Jesus and who
David David I mean they're they're three
Muslims that's what I know
I don't have too many thoughts on Moses
like I don't know much about him yeah
Moses was another wasn't just a just
another very important Prophet you know
bringing forth the Ten Commandments and
bringing messages of God and then you
know I know Jesus came along and was
like Hey Moses he was into him too
I don't I don't have a scholarly answer
on that one either what do you tell me
your thoughts like what made you ask
that question because I I really I have
so much more to learn okay so the reason
I asked is because you know I grew up
Catholic and then from Catholicism
um I you know branched into Christianity
I became atheist for a while because of
a lot of things were happening in my
life I was um
it's kind of angry because I didn't
understand like if if God existed why
why am I experiencing these things like
why is this going on here but I came
back and I started looking into like all
different religions like Hinduism
that always on Buddhism
all this stuff and I ended up back in
Christianity and from there I had a lot
of questions and the more that I read
the Bible I was just very curious very
very curious and the reason I ask is
because when I found out about Moses and
I was you know learning more about Moses
I was learning that okay Moses had many
great
Miracles that he did
you know maybe part of this Red Sea yeah
yeah
it's pretty dope I'm not gonna lie to
you it's pretty dope and then from there
I started seeing the um
I get my mind I'm like kind of like
seeing oh well like okay what was this
peace responded to this when Jesus
speaks upon us he did this and now I'm
looking at the other prophets and I'm
seeing that each Prophet that I'm
looking into they're also like they have
their own miracles
as well and a question that I had and I
genuinely like it's a genuine question
and I want to know what you think as
well and please don't think that I'm
like
trying to attack and at all because
thank you genuine question
I asked the pastors I said if you have
all these Prophets
that were chosen by God
they all came with the same message even
the same message that Jesus says
and they all have performed miracles
just as Jesus says then why now are we
saying that Jesus
is
the Creator
when there were many times when I was
reading the Bible that um he was asked
about like the day of judgment and stuff
like this and he was saying that that
knowledge is with the father alone
and that he he doesn't have this
knowledge
no one in this world has his knowledge
and it was just genuine questions like
that so yeah that's interesting yeah
it's genuine questions I have so I just
want to know that's why I asked that's a
I mean that's a that's a great question
and uh what I know about it is that he
did Jesus did come and say that he was
God he's a hundred percent God and 100
human that's what we learned
um at the same time but I but yeah I I
guess he didn't put it that way but he
did come and from the very beginning
referred to himself as the son of man
which I just learned this so I'm gonna
spit a fact like I know what I'm talking
about for a second here and um back in
the Book of Daniel in the Old Testament
there was a there was a prophecy that
the you know Daniel had a dream that the
someone calling the son of man calling
himself the son of man would would be
coming and he was the deity with all
power over all things
so he did say he did distinguish himself
in that way from the other prophets
and he yeah so and there will be people
will say well Jesus never said he was
God and but he did
and there was another instance
um where he was
when he was walking on water
and he said
fear not I am and in the I am he was
repeating language that God had actually
spoken to Moses at one point
um so he
I think that's answers your question and
I don't know if they answered it at the
time but
that and that but then for me that
raises the question of
you know 600 years later Muhammad comes
along and as I'm learning about your
religion
you know
how does that jive how does that jive
with Jesus saying he's God you know and
the Holy Trinity and I know that there's
a conversation around well the whole
Trinity can exist but
um it's almost like branches of the same
tree for to use an imperfect analogy is
how we see it
yeah and this is this is why like I have
that genuine curiosity and this is what
led me to
I guess even
consider reading the Quran because at
this point I'm still Christian I'm still
you know looking into these things and
it was like a genuine question like okay
if all this is this then how come you
have this Prophet this final final
profit that comes down and he's saying
the same message that every single the
prophet has said
and
he makes claims and the claims that he
made is that uh this is preserved and it
will continue to be preserved and
to this day the Quran
is preserved so this is like it just
raised genuine questions inside of me
and this is like again this is not what
actually led me to Islam this is just
what arise curiosity and questions right
and this is why I ask
because I see that you're starting to
look into these things so I just I want
to know where you guys are at
yeah which so the Quran hasn't changed
at all right no
wow how many times has the like what's
the difference from the Bible so this is
this is what I'm learning so the word on
the street is that the Bible's change
and it's all been made it's all been
redone and it continues to be Rewritten
but it hasn't
so I'm reading that you've heard me
mention the the movie the case for
Christ
I'm like bell ringing sound from someone
who's the dog
we forgot to take off his collar sorry
yeah he likes to he he always and he
always likes to you know get his get his
moment in the spotlight and yeah
he is very handsome if you ever get if
we ever put him on
um so it
I'm reading the the we watched the movie
the case for Christ about a man named a
journalist very
um acclaimed journalist who decided to
try to prove that Jesus Christ wasn't
real
and that he wasn't really the the
Messiah and that the resurrection was a
forest and all that and he set out to to
do that and in doing it he discovered he
could find nothing but more and more and
more evidence and proof that it was
in fact true and it really did happen
and so I'm reading the so the book that
he that he wrote on it because the movie
is you know dramatization and it's a
really good starting place but I'm
reading his book and there and he he
talked with
uh archaeologists biblical Scholars
theologians historical Scholars
um medical doctors psychologists I'm
only 100 pages in and I'm already
overwhelmed with how much I've learned
I'm already planning on finishing it and
going back to page one so I can learn
these things and use those as a
springboard for more research
but one of the things he talks about is
that you know very early on it was the
four gospels that were that actually
have tremendous consistency
and they have not changed they have
consistency with each other on all the
main points and they have
not changed throughout the years and
then there you know there's all these
other books that were written by
different people as the years went on
but all the things that are written in
the first 100 150 years after Christ's
death are considered to be the most
valid
um based on the same standards that are
applied to any historical documents
so it's a myth
and the stuff that you're reading it it
shows the actual sources where like it
shows that there is no change
yeah yeah it shows that exactly that and
it'll show where there are changes
um that things were changed in
Translation they're acknowledged and uh
clarified or explained do people
memorize the Bible
isn't that a thing with the Quran like
people memorize it yeah Romi do you want
to go into that a little bit Yeah tell
us about that yeah so Allah says in the
Quran
um that he I'm gonna paraphrase a little
bit but he he revealed the Quran in the
way so it's it's Compact and it's easy
to to remember
so I think there's about maybe 6 000
verses in the Quran and it's it's
presented in a way where it's very easy
to remember you can maybe see it as like
it Rhymes a lot of the time it has a lot
of the same words used multiple times so
it's it's not difficult for even kids to
memorize and that's why you have many
kids around the world
not just the Muslim majority countries
but even here in the west who spend two
years memorizing the Quran and they
remember it basically for the rest of
their life um and this is why the Quran
was so preserved because from the very
beginning this is what the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him taught the
people to do and that the Quran actually
means that which is recited so it's
supposed to be a book that's memorized
and recited before it's written down in
red although both methods of
preservation are valid so we had the
companions who learned the Quran from
the prophet peace be upon himself
and they also wrote it down in various
places and they taught the people of
Quran and then they taught people and
they taught so you have basically both
forms of preservation for the last 1400
years and that's why Muslims are so
certain and even historians are so
certain that the Quran has been
preserved basically for those two main
reasons I do want to jump in um
on the discussion from earlier because I
went to a Catholic School
um before I started practicing Islam I
was born into a Muslim family but you
know how it is growing up in the west
you just you know kind of go with the
flow and eventually hopefully you find
God and then you know if you're serious
enough you jump into it so I went to
Catholic School
um and basically integrate 10 a grade
11. I came across some videos about
Islam and I started looking more and
more into it all while kind of learning
the basic Christian concepts of the
Trinity and and Adam how he's expelled
from heaven and all that stuff and uh so
I want an adventure and I was always
Muslim or I was never really really
Christian I don't want to you know want
I don't want people to think that I'm
claiming I was because I wasn't but
I did look into both and I did a lot of
research and I found majority of the
arguments that I've heard from
Christians
um are the ones that are
I would I don't want to say like taught
but I would say they're not exactly in
the Bible or if they are it's with that
narrative that Jesus is God to begin
with and just to give a quick example of
one this one I actually found really
interesting because it took me a while
to find this
um with Jesus being the son of man one
of my my earlier Christian friends his
name was sathi presented this to me and
I didn't really try and combat it
because I didn't know how and then later
like years later I came across you know
for example Ezekiel being called son of
man like 90 times in the Bible as well
so you know that would raise some alarms
for some people and myself include it's
like if Jesus is the son of man why is
Ezekiel also being called the son of man
uh in this kind of enlightening way
that's interesting and um I can uh it's
actually in the Book of Ezekiel I think
from the very beginning all throughout
it's kind of like a theme it's like he
has a dream oh son of man you know uh
take the scripture o son of man eat what
is before you and go speech the people
of Israel you know Osama and so on and
so forth
so I just you know I found things like
that very interesting and um
I guess while while I'm at it also
things like um what's a common one
um
um the father-in-law and I are one you
know that's a really really common one a
lot of Christians um mention but if you
read throughout the Old Testament or
sorry the New Testament you find Jesus
says about the disciples let them be one
as I am in you the father and you are in
me so he's saying the same way me and
the father are one let the 12 disciples
be one so is this one in being now are
they one person and there's more context
given when you read what Paul wrote I
forget exactly where but he said the one
who plants the seed and the one who
Waters it are one
so this shows that it's like they're one
in purpose now and it's beautiful
because you had mentioned the
similarities between Christianity
Judaism and Islam and I I loved what I
was hearing because there are genuinely
so many
um similarities and when we first made
the video I was just kind of stuck on
the differences so when you had
mentioned that I was like well it's
fairly different it's going to be hard
for us to you know unite and all that
stuff but um thinking about it now
especially with your kind of goal with
religion having a good Community having
a good relationship with God these are
things that are so strongly encouraged
in Islam that you basically cannot have
Islam without those things that's how
fundamental these things are to our
religion
um uh even things like um
there is something you mentioned about
the community and how Jesus could turn
these people you know who hated each
other or were very far from each other
into loving people into good people to
go and transform Society I found that
very beautiful because that's what we
believe Jesus you know or any Prophet
messenger can do and when you look at
the prophet Muhammad I think this is a
great resemblance between the two
um he peace be upon him he came to a
tribe that was tribalistic he went to a
people that were tribalistic literally
like engaging in Tribal Wars doing like
horrendous things and he basically got
all of them to unite in a way where
unless basically in a few decades they
conquered Rome the same Romans that were
persecuting Jesus they were stronger
back then
um and the Persians as well
you know this Muslim small little like
Bedouin Arab people got together under
the banner of believing in one God they
dispelled all they are basically hatred
for each other and they once showed up
on the Romans doorstep and conquered
them they went to the Persian showed up
on the doorstep and conquered them they
went basically to the borders of China
they went essentially all around the
world and now we have you know Islam
basically worldwide today
so that's cool yeah that's that's
something that's always been surprising
um to me but I want to hear a little
more from you and and sunny as well
when it comes to Islam especially in the
beginning when you know you heard Andrew
take convert and all that and up until
now when you're learning all these
things about some I know you mentioned
scientific Miracles what has really
stood out to you
um that makes you think wow you know
that's something that's special because
you seem to have a keen sense of
Interest
I'd probably say the scientific Miracles
that's kind of more of the stuff that
I'm into so hearing all of
the Miracles that couldn't have possibly
been known at the time but are proven to
be true now I probably thought that that
was the most
um I guess remarkable thing inside of it
what would you say you know is it the
scientific stuff or is it like I feel
like it would be the similarities for
you
um the scientific stuff is fascinating
another thing is um
it's not in the Quran but the biggest
thing I've noticed about Islam is like
the Brotherhood with it so I've talked
about this there's like this might be a
bad example but with like black dudes or
something if they're at a party where
it's like mostly white people they have
like that connection and with Christians
and stuff I feel like there isn't that
as much of a connection where you know
you meet another Christian and it's like
oh that's it's like everyone it just
goes like everyone's a Christian if you
tell someone that it doesn't really mean
as much but then I've been out with
Muslims where they meet other Muslims
and they're like Habibi and then they're
like um they have like that Brotherhood
and I'm like uh that that also stands
out to me and it it oh go ahead I'll let
you know that's that's the majority of
my point and I I countered you on this I
counted you on this because he made it
seem in his first commentary on it that
it was like no one else does this and
I'm like all right that's not true
that's not true first of all just
culturally Italians do like them men
there's there's a handshake and a hug
and a kiss among men uh and it's regular
and it's you know it's very warm
um now that I'm in a different type of
church where I'm now making uh
acquaintances and friends with people
who are can actually I can actually talk
about the Bible with there is like this
whole other level connection so what I
think the difference is is is that you
know you guys take your religion you
know you let your religion drive your
life
and so here I'm finding Christians who
let their religion who let their belief
in God let God run you know the whole
Jesus Take the Wheel thing is very real
and uh it's not just an expression that
you use when things are going wrong like
just let them drive all the time because
he knows better is is really more of the
mindset and so I I feel that
with those you know peasants to use an
Italian expression and it's a it which
is a means brother is a Brotherhood you
know or Sisterhood and so I I just don't
think it's as unique as Sunny does but I
think the real point is that Sonny's
impressed by it and I think it is
impressive
you know that that closeness and that
Brotherhood that before we came on live
tonight Rami you you said the other
brothers aren't here yet and I said oh
your brothers like I thought you were
real you know you were three brothers
and he said no no just in the
Brotherhood I was all right cool yeah
I'm making so and I think that's
beautiful
yeah it's it goes to say that like it
can be found elsewhere it's not just in
Islam where you find this Brotherhood or
Sisterhood as well for the Sisters
but it's in Islam we're told by the
Prophet Muhammad in one of the hadiths
now the hadiths or narrations it's
basically what the prophet said
um and they're all authenticated so any
Hadith that we take to be as like okay
he actually said this there's a chain of
narration that you have Scholars who are
actually doing due diligence and like
really just going through a process to
either credit it or discredit it now in
one of these hadiths the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
he said that
um you should love for your brother
what you love for yourself
and that's something that if you look in
the Bible
it it's fairly in the it's fairly in the
same that you should love for
um
exactly it's the same it's the same
message correct but the thing is like
where do you see it most applied is so
for the most part in this land like you
just see
people even people that don't really
practice they're Muslim but they they
don't really practice even they
have that Brotherhood and The Sisterhood
with other Muslims it's a very very
it's a very amazing thing to be honest
where you could be Muslim
and someone all the way across the world
you've never met them you don't know
them you don't know anything about them
but because you're Muslim because you
share that faith and because they love
for you what they will love for
themselves if you were going to go over
across seas and be with them they would
accept you into their house they would
take care of you as if you were their
own like the the hospitality the family
type vibe that I've felt from Muslims
the only other place that I've ever felt
that is my own family
um so it's there's something there for
sure
that's cool and I and I have half foot
outside of my own family and in other
communities
um so I stand by my like it's not unique
but it is special it is special no
matter where it's coming from but I but
I do love I do love that it is it is so
so part of your call your culture to me
that makes it much stronger and and much
more credible oh I want to go back to
the the original question though like so
he said you know what was it that's most
interesting because that that was really
what you where you came up that you
really loved that about it
um the scientific
um Revelations that were passed on to
Muhammad are killer that is so cool I
can't say enough about the
um learning about that and knowing what
I know about you know Modern Life I just
found that to give tremendous
credibility to Muhammad as a prophet
because there's no other way he could
have known that
you know yes some may what they did with
Jesus call him a sorcerer or something
you know like whatever like okay that's
like a
vacuous
uh argument right against it so I find
that to be so credible and impressive
and and just fascinating but then there
are other things that really stood out
for me that I haven't had time to
research like uh somewhere in the Quran
that said that Jesus was talking he was
a talking baby I was just gonna mention
that talking baby
like I I I haven't had time to really
research it on my end on the Christian
side but you know in 12 years of
Catholic school I think I would have
remembered that and I don't think it's
something that's in the Bible yeah I
have to confirm that so you know that's
where I get a little um like the
historical the historical differences
and doesn't the Quran say Jesus wasn't
crucified or um yeah right right and
there was actually a lot of a lot of
historical proof that he was so those
two things are are sticking points for
me and it doesn't discredit the religion
for me because I you know but it does
historically I need to do a lot more
homework because
I I do tend to
believe something that was written
within a hundred years of Jesus's death
as being more accurate than something
that was written about Jesus 600 years
later right whether it was written by
Muhammad or anybody yeah yeah that's 100
100 yeah I think that's very fair oh
sorry sorry please finish yeah no that's
it that's it that was a really super
interesting points though
I was gonna say that's always been a
bigger struggle of mine with religion is
differentiating like myth with what's
factual so we'd hear stuff like Adam and
Eve and the Ark and stuff and that's
considered like not you know uh
historical truth but it's supposed to
mean something else so then I would hear
it like walking on water and all those
other stories and I would have trouble
differentiating what is meant to be
taken literally and what's meant to be
taken as I guess myth is that is do you
guys know
um in your knowledge because I don't it
is the is the ark for example meant to
be a myth or is it meant to be a
historical you know act that we
understood and that one day an
archaeologist May dig up that Arc
yeah so yeah with Islam when it comes to
these stories we don't have this um this
worry that oh there's no historical
evidence of Moses therefore he didn't
exist because what's really important is
when you're looking at a religion in
regards to any kind of secular study
like history or archeology it's very
important to understand this both the
religion and the study itself when you
look at history uh and I think there's
something Bart Ehrman mentioned who's a
historian and New Testament scholar he
said that historical truths on the
paraphrase are not like facts historical
facts are not like it 100 happened like
you exist and I exist as a fact you know
historical truths are only probabilistic
truths the job of the historian is to
tell you what most likely happened
because using you can have a document
that says that says you know
um
um on Hobie Romney and arm wrestle but
obviously that's not possible so that
document is clearly wrong
so obviously that document is clearly
wrong so the job the historian is to
show what most likely happened so you'll
you'll and by the way I want to add that
the reason kind of Christians or people
who who believe in the Bible some of
them want to say that these are myths is
because of things like you know when
Evolution comes they some of them kind
of folded over and with things like the
belief that the universe is six thousand
years old I know not everyone Christian
not every Christian believes that but
some of them have adopted Well it can't
be literal
um for these reasons you know that that
would mean the flood would have would
would be less than six thousand years
ago and there was no great flood six
thousand years ago there was a flood
much much earlier than that a great
flood and if you look up Mountain Judy
it's in Turkey you'll see some pictures
of uh crevice that looks like a boat
landed in it and it's really interesting
because side note the Quran says that
the ark landed on Mount Judy so that's
why it was so fascinating for Muslims
when they see that that's wild yeah see
that's cool have you been to any places
where you had like crazy I don't know if
Revelations is the right word but you
felt like something
uh significant when you went somewhere
whether it was a place like Mount Judy
or anything like that that's all fire
real fired yeah we haven't heard
anything from you I want to hear it
besides the Lakers
is that the Dodgers hat right the
Dodgers so I went to I went to umrah
which is kind of like a pilgrimage right
so in Islam we have one of the five
pillars of Islam which is called Hajj
and Hajj is the actual pilgrimage that
were ordained or I guess prescribed as
Muslims to do at least once in our life
if we have the ability financially
mentally physically to do so
um but umrah is kind of like a voluntary
mini pilgrimage right so when I went to
do that in Saudi Arabia in Mecca there's
a place it's a mountain it's called and
when you go to that mountain it's like
an arduous climb it was it was pretty
rough I did this with my mother and when
you get to the top that's basically the
place that Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was when he would get
Revelation that's when he that's where
he was when he first got um Angel
Gabriel peace be upon him who came and
uh gave Revolution basically so when I
first went there just the emotions being
there and just feeling that wow this is
where he was peace be upon him getting
Revelation to spread Islam to mankind it
was it was a different type of feeling
than just studying about it or reading
about it physically being there it's a
game changer
Christians tell similar stories of going
to Calvary and you know Bethlehem and
all the places where certain big
historical things happen and I think
that you know where Muhammad got his
Revelations and where these these other
prophets had these special moments there
must be something
energetically special about them on the
earth and I I do believe that that has
to be real and it could probably be
measured by some scientific tool that
doesn't exist yet or may even exist
already
on that note I I didn't want to mention
this because it's a little like maybe
crazy but there's a video on it they
they say when you look at the surface of
the Earth the center of it which I know
sounds crazy because the Earth is a
sphere or a spherical
um they say that the center of it is
actually the Kaaba in Mecca like the
where if I had one and they say that
because this is where most of the energy
is kind of expelled from from the earth
and this is where we face when we we put
like we pray like Moses and Jesus and
David all did in the prophet peace upon
them with their head on the floor and
maybe this is a little too theoretical
but you know some I've heard at least in
the video that we are basically
expelling certain energy kind of like
grounding yourself and to know that
basically all this energy is being
exerted from that place outward
um and they did measure this you know
scientifically speaking if you want
there's a video on it I can link it for
you guys after it's interesting yeah
please do but um when you mentioned that
I was like hey I have to mention it also
because that that was crazy when I first
heard it but um hmm have you it's it's
so Angel uh it feels like a thing you
would have been most likely to read
because you went on a spiritual journey
outside of Christianity and before you
got to Islam and all that but there was
this book about 25 years ago it came out
called The Celestine Prophecy and
you remember it and I think I I've heard
about it if I ready I can't recall 100
but I'm I definitely heard this it was a
big it was a big splash and everybody
was going to become spiritual the whole
world and then we blew it right but
um as you as we do so so it the the real
gist of it was talking about the the
spiritual energy of everything on Earth
and how through meditation you can
actually see the energy like you can see
the energy between you two people and
how it changes when there's love and
peace and when they're arguing or any
other thing and you can look at a body
of a forest of trees and see the
connective energy between them and so
you know the some people hear this and
think that I'm some kind of a nut but
there was a time when I was meditating a
lot you know like an hour a day and I
could see that
and you can see it between between your
own fingertips it's really wild
and it's really awesome and that's what
makes me really truly believe that what
fayad was saying about his experience
there is because there is special
energy there that you know that we that
you can't see with the regular naked eye
but that exists there and maybe you
could see it if you really were in that
space and even though it's a
non-religious book I think it's really
super valuable for religious people
because
meditation uh you know and prayer go
hand in hand I you know oh no I was just
gonna say Mother Teresa and I love this
quote that she said
um prayer is talking to God and
meditation is listening to God yeah yeah
and I think it's good for everybody
no matter what your religion is so I was
gonna ask this might be Haram I don't
know but do Muslims have any experience
or do they talk about like psychedelics
or anything at all were you kind of
I don't know get to feel that different
energy in a way that it's kind of hard
to explain or is that not really I get a
whole podcast on that yeah yeah so okay
yeah so psychedelics any substance in
Islam is seen as Haram forbidden why is
this it's because there's a saying where
if you want to ask God something you
pick the phone up and when God gives you
the message you put the phone down you
hang up because that's it like he's
giving you something that 10 times out
of 10 is going to be so much that you
really have to sit with that and like
really reflect on it before you can
actually put it to use when you take a
psychedelic it's as if you pick the
phone up
and you can't put it down until the
psychedelic trip is over so while people
receive many different things and while
people experience many different things
they see different things and all this
stuff
God says in the Quran that in these
things there's some benefit but the harm
outweighs the benefit
and so if the phone is picked up and you
can't put the phone down
let's say you receive a hundred messages
from God
how are you going to make use of these
hundred messages
if you receive one you have to you have
to hang up the phone immediately so
imagine you you received a hundred you
it's just it keeps coming in you're just
like oh I can't take no more no you're
gonna take more because you can't put it
down you took this substance you're no
longer in control now something else is
in control and again like is this is a
good in it very little but the the harm
for our ways the benefit because if
we're talking about energy
if we're talking about this stuff and
like you're meditating and you're
starting to see these things and you see
ah there's actually something that you
go to a place and you feel something
weird have you ever walked into a place
and you could feel something really bad
it's we I talk about this all the time
like I'm not the most religious person
but I'm like really big on energy and
with the way you say stuff is really
important and I have I mean it's not
like I'm like you know a saint or
nothing but I always have like a weird
feeling whenever I this sounds dumb
whenever I leave something at home or
something I like know in my gut until
the second I find it and then it goes
away it's like a radar when you like
don't put your seat belt on and then
when I click it in or grab whatever I
missed and it's that same kind of
feeling when you go into certain places
or you're going into a decision or
something and you still have that same
feeling deep down but I feel like it's
really just a matter of being able to
communicate with that it could be it's
we call it intuition but it could be God
telling you like tapping you on the
shoulder
yeah so in dingbat you left the toaster
on yeah it could be God or it could be a
something God gave us who knows yeah but
another thing I've seen is like how your
your stomach it's not like another brain
but yes yes you guys have looked into
this is the second brain yeah it is oh
well then I'm not even crazy so your gut
is like the second brain and the food
that they give us nowadays is like such
garbage that it like destroys that
connection that you'd be able to have
with those senses Google the Mind gut
connection and you'll be you'll have
five years of research
right it's just so interesting to see
all that stuff and then it seems like
like that is some of the most important
stuff you can know and be in touch with
and they don't teach you that at all in
school in fact they give you like food
that's so garbage like have you ever
seen Public School food or anything like
that oh it's like it's poison it's legit
poison
it's it's just weird to see how yeah it
feels like there's such an active agenda
not just with school but everything to
push you away from that kind of stuff
you know yeah and it's crazy if you guys
should look into this
um you have all this food you have all
these chemicals these GMOs you have all
these
things that are in the air that we can't
actually see right and they're affecting
us internally not just not just good
but our actual brain like there's this
gland within our brain called the pineal
gland if they should look into it as we
grow older this gland begins to calcify
it forms like a layer of calcium over it
why does it do this it's because
of the fluoride is because of the
hormones is because of all this stuff
facts in our environment that our body
is trying to almost like cycle out like
trying to like filter it out and it's
being deposited right here so again
there's many things here and what's
crazy is that okay you have all this
stuff not if you were too fast
have you ever done a water fast by any
chance
no I I sometimes do intermittent fasting
while just eat like once a day that way
yeah yeah the most focused on work
because if I eat it's pretty nice right
it is nice like today actually I kind of
did that I didn't eat till we sat down
on the call so I was able to stay
focused yeah right when I woke up what
is the water what what does a water fast
do for you have you done it yeah I've
done I've done water first but the whole
point I'm trying to make is is if anyone
fast like your son he does the well one
minute it's intermittent fasting with
this when you go x amount of time
without eating your body begins to if
you spend long enough if you spend about
23 to 24 hours your body goes into a
state known as autophagy
um if you keep going your body goes into
ketosis and your body is just God has
created your body in such a way where it
functions amazingly now the whole point
I'm trying to make is that when you fast
you're actually allowing your body to
heal itself you allowing your body to
cleanse itself so that's why when you
fast or more specifically Muslims were
prescribed fasting during the month of
Ramadan now in this month of Ramadan you
are yeah from from sunrise to sunset no
water no food
I mean thank God it's in December but
geez it's amazing
no it's random times like oh it actually
it moves with you yeah it's not it's not
Sunrise bro it's from dungeon oh my bad
not bad what's the difference what's the
difference between sunrise the first so
we have five daily prayers as Muslims
right I'm sure most people know that the
first prayer is called fudger so that
happens when it's done which is about an
hour to two give or take from Sunrise so
as soon as it hits done that's when we
gotta start fasting and we go basically
until said which is sunset yeah and in
that time it's not even a water fast
it's a dry fast so no food no water no
medications more or less no intimacy
with your spouse it's just full-on
abstaining from your basic impulses and
desires yeah yeah but I got a big point
I'm trying to get at here all right so
when we do this fast when anyone does
this fast even if you look at
non-muslims who they do the fast because
maybe they're in a Muslim country at the
time or maybe they just have friends
that are Muslim and they want to try it
out with them
when they do this they become more
spiritual they feel more in tune with
the Creator and it's like they start to
feel things more because again the gut
is beginning to heal the gut is the
second brain the whole body begins to
heal and the whole point I want to get
at here is if we're talking about energy
if we walk into a place
and you immediately feel something off
this is your gut this is something
that's intuitive it's in your intuition
it's something that's it's real you
can't see it though it's real right like
Elena that's your name correct yeah
so you said you were meditating and you
were seeing these things and if you were
to tell people people would say you're
probably crazy because they've never
they've probably never seen
but the thing is like you ask anyone
who's maybe done meditation long enough
or you've asked anyone who's done
psychedelics they'll tell you yeah it's
real like I've seen this I've seen this
so it's crazy that it's actually real
these places where this energy is
actually real and it means that this
reality is not all that there is it
means that there's other things that of
which we cannot perceive and if we do
then it's a very very slight
and in the in the Quran God says he
mentions of a different creation that he
made which these are called the Jinn
and the Jinn they are he describes them
as being in a place where they can see
us but we can't see them
and this is this is just to um emphasize
the fact that
you know what you were experiencing when
you were meditating like it's it's real
and by the way the celestial yeah
Celestial prophecy I never really I just
remember now this girl that I was
working with back in like
2015 nothing she told me about this and
she was really really spiritual at the
time
it's very cool read no no go on that's
it okay I just wanted to touch on the
point that angel said about uh you know
Jin so in Islam we have these creations
aside from human beings called Jinn and
they're very similar to you know you
guys call them demons right it's the
same thing and there's one thing
particularly that I wanted to kind of
ask you guys but in Christianity Satan
is a fallen angel correct yes
in Islam the Quran through you know the
Quran Allah tells us that shaytan or you
know Iblis who's Satan is not a fallen
angel It's a gin
and this is kind of cool because when I
found that out I always wondered why in
Christianity they you know you guys
believe that it's a fallen angel because
wouldn't God create an angel who is kind
of you know for the purpose of just
obeying God's Commandments and being
kind of just solely instructed for that
one thing so when I found out that oh
how could something that God created
fall
of course like that when it was solely
created without Free Will without any
you know I guess capability of
comprehension or thought or free will
how could that happen and then when I
found out that in Islam we believe that
you know Satan is a Jinn to me that was
kind of different and I guess it just
appealed a little bit more to me but I
want to know your thoughts on that so I
he was a an archangel which is you know
like a top level
Executive Vice President Angel and I do
believe they had free will but you know
I have to and now I have to verify that
so that that I think is why he was able
to fall
or the others did not
but it's it's a good question and now I
want to know yeah because in Islam the
angels don't have free will
yeah and if you actually this is where
I'm kind of like now curious you you
said that it's supposed to be from your
research there's um there's certain
things within the Bible that have not
changed
okay and where this thing that we're
saying now about Satan you know when
he's being referred to as a an angel an
archangel like where exactly in the
Bible was this and if it if it's in a
place where it was altered well then how
how much can you actually believe what
was being said and if you if if we see
the angels as having no free will but
then we see the Gin Gin or another
creation kind of like us they also have
free will they also live like us they
also eat like us they also have families
like us they have the choice whether
they want to do good whether they want
to do bad whether they want to worship
God whether they don't want to worship
got so it's like in the Quran Satan was
this Jinn that was like
basically the top of the top like how
you said this archangelist the top of
the table he was his gin that was the
top of the top that so much so that he
was actually brought close
to God and when God was creating Adam
first he he first he made the body he
made the body as if like imagine this
like empty vessel this like empty clay
thing or this empty like I don't know
just like a statue or something like
this right he made this statue and he's
basically saying like this is this is my
creation and then he's telling all the
angels to prostrate
and um at least Satan didn't prostrate
he didn't prostate because he was
looking at this he was like knocking on
it going in going out of it and he's
like I'm not going to prostrate to this
because I'm better than this like you
made me of a smokeless fire yet here you
made this creation of of dirt
like I I'm not going to I'm not going to
prostrate to that and from there that's
that's ever against that's what caused
his fall and you see that in the Bible
too it was it was the fall of the
arrogance that caused him to fall so
then he came back and he like said eat
the apple
and he was like I'm gonna run this guy
right or something like that uh I'm
gonna I'm just gonna look up like did
archangels have free will because
I I really I may not find the answer
quickly this may be deeper than than all
that but
yeah so I I think generally and
obviously there's different
denominations I think generally
Christians think that um
according to Google page one he had
Lucifer had Free Will okay we'll go
deeper later sorry go ahead mommy no
worries noise yeah that's that's what
Christians believe in and it's it's
usually basically it helps justify the
idea that Satan was a fallen angel
because it's just a difference of belief
Christians believe angels have free will
Muslims don't it's just a different
syntheology it's not something too too
important just different viewpoints
um but yeah long story short basically
Satan afterwards he he swore he made
basically a promise that I'm going to
try my best to misguide everyone and
Allah said listen you won't misguide
anyone except those who like basically
are they don't mind being astray no they
don't actually want the truth they don't
want to be guided but my servants the
ones that obey me basically try go try
see what happens and alhamdulillah you
know we're still very very strong and uh
some of us are Untouchable not speaking
of myself but some people are just you
know there's actually a Hadith narration
of of one of the companions of the
Prophet The Prophet peace upon him he
said when he sees this when when Satan
sees this companion walking he basically
walks the other way
he doesn't even try with them
that's you know hopefully the the level
we hope to get to but I want to bring
this conversation
yeah and may Allah allow us to get to
that point I mean I mean I want to bring
this conversation back to the kind of
uh basic theological discussion
um you had mentioned Elena that the
prophet peace upon Him is a true prophet
of God and you realize that through some
of the things he prophesied and revealed
like for example the scientific miracles
in the Quran is that true
I know I do I do see him as a prophet
absolutely and so I think we have
differing opinions on on other things
but uh so far anyway but yes I do he
absolutely is a prophet that's very
beautiful very beautiful and sunny would
you agree with that yeah I'd agree all
right beautiful and the reason I asked
is because
I want to give a brief basic summary on
Islam because I really genuinely think
you guys will resonate with it and Elena
with what you were describing before
with wanting Community wanting that
relationship with God there's no way I
can communicate to you how
how important this is in Islam and how
easy it is to get there
um for example just fasting like the
brothers mentioned is something you just
instantly feel close with God so I want
to bring it to a very basic level and
I'll actually start with the Old
Testament I want us to think about this
from a historical perspective and it
really helped me understand things when
I looked at it in this way you have at
the time of pharaoh and Moses peace be
upon him
God sends the messenger and Prophet
Moses to his people to deliver them from
Pharaoh correct
to the point where God split the sea
right God caused allowed Moses to split
the sea for the children of Israel to go
through and then he destroyed his
enemies with that sea yeah and all God
said was hear Israel your Lord God is
one he does not resemble anything that
flies in the sky that walks in the Earth
or that swims in the sea and then as
soon as Moses left they worshiped the
golden a golden calf they made a statue
and they worshiped it and Moses got back
and he was like almost biting his
fingers in in Anger at these people
because in truth we need to only worship
one God who is not something that we can
mold or fashion or we can create or we
can you know give birth to her or
anything like that God is someone who is
there's nothing comparable to him if you
think you see God then you're wrong
that's not God you know I think that's a
very easy way of putting it
so Islam says this God created Adam
and Eve and he sent prophets and
Messengers all with the same exact
message
you are my creation and I created you to
worship me alone so obey my prophets and
obey my messengers receive my Revelation
and accept it uh and and take it into
your life make it a part of your life
obey my Commandments and I will reward
you with heaven every single Prophet
came with this message all these
Israelite prophets all the non-israelite
prophets and then you get to Jesus peace
be upon him
and his message as we find is no
different
he had the same first commandment when
the young Jewish man came to him he
asked him about the first commandment he
said hero Israel your Lord God is one
worship one God Alone
and when you delve Through the Bible and
I'm sure you're familiar with a lot of
these verses you find very very clear
sayings like the father is greater than
I
I can do nothing of my own of authority
you know no one knows of the hour not
the son not the angels in heaven no one
except the father alone knows the hour
yeah he did he did indicate that in
certain things like he would say Well
only my father knows this or that yeah
100 and the Islamic perspective on the
Bible is not that it's like 100 wrong
throw it away actually one the one the
companions brought the Bible the Old
Testament to the prophet he said this is
a good book that's actually what he said
because there are things in there that
we believe is is legit like when Moses
went to his people and said you know
worship one God alone and when he
condemned them for worshiping the
worshiping golden calf and when Jesus
came and he said
um you know the father is greater than I
worship one God alone all these things
we believe Jesus said that 100 but what
happened and I mentioned this in the
original video I don't know if you if
you guys watched it or not what happened
Jesus and I'm willing to claim this
strongly got Lost in Translation loss in
transmission now what does that mean
that means Jesus very clearly came he
had one message but after he left we
don't believe he died you guys doing I
want to talk about that a little bit
towards the end after he left
there were people that came and claimed
things about Jesus and the religion that
Jesus himself and even some of the
disciples never claimed for example Paul
went to the Romans and he told them
basically don't worry about the law you
don't have to circumvent you know you
don't have to circumcise your children
you don't have to abandon eating pork
and drinking you don't have to you know
not be adulterers or whatever you can do
whatever you want just believe Jesus
died for your sins and he basically
invented this father-son Holy Spirit
thing the only instance of the father
son holy spirit being mentioned is in in
one of the gospels where they're being
baptized in the name of the father son
of Holy Spirit but there is no
description the Trinity of God being uh
you know three persons who are co-equal
co-eternal
um in every possible way came 300 years
yes 300 years after Jesus and the
Council of nicaea even Paul himself
believed that the father was an
authority over Jesus because he wrote
that um the head of man is Christ and
the head of Christ is the father so
my my main thing is that you have all
these reiterations these changes from
subordinationism to separationism to
dualism to modalism all these different
understandings of who God is one of the
most basic beautiful clear one that
Jesus came with was there the whole time
worship one God Alone he doesn't
resemble anything that walks that flies
that swims is not something you can you
know imagine or see or comprehend just
know that he created you to worship him
so that's why when Allah sent the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him it
was to bring back this message that
Moses had that Noah had that Abraham had
that Jesus had worshiped one God alone
and denounce the false Idols so when you
look at Deuteronomy and you see where it
says if a prophet speaks a prophecy that
ends up being true then he is a prophet
of God and you guys see that even by
biblical standards the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon Him is a true prophet and
his I would say correcting the false and
it's very beautifully outlined in the
Quran Allah says that the Christians say
Jesus is the son of God but they're just
reiterating the things the lies that
they heard from people before them
and that's the Islamic sense it's very
simple very clear worship on God alone
all the prophets said that the prophet
Muhammad is the last prophet in this
chain and if you want you know if you
intend goodness for yourself for your
community for your people and if you
want to worship God
except the Quran is the word of Allah
which was delivered to the prophet peace
upon him the prophet Muhammad is Allah
messenger of God and the Muslims are
ready to accept you guys into the
community
take you as a brother and sister in
Islam all right but Jesus is coming back
any minute so you know
that we have that to contend with too
right okay I hope one of them comes back
because we need them I don't know 100
how they'd be how the world I joke but
we do
um no I thank you for that and I you
know I really do
um I do just you know what I'm studying
though is and I I have to become better
versed because I really want to have
this conversation on a more intellectual
level with you like truly
um as well as you know the theological
level but
there there was some part of it there
was some scene where Jesus was being
baptized I Believe by John the Baptist
where he there was a mention of at that
point the holy spirit being present and
God being present and you know yes he
did he did acknowledge the differences
in himself and and God and the Holy
Spirit but he also it's my understanding
that in his teachings he did talk about
them as a if he didn't use the word
Trinity as a as a single being so I want
to revisit that with you I want to do a
little bit more homework on it because I
hear a lot of things that you know oh
this is what's what and then I do more
homework on it and I hear other opinions
and you know I want to really get the
full the full picture
um
you know then there's Jesus's death you
mentioned yeah yeah we could talk about
that now if you're curious about the
Islamic uh position because um when
Sunny mentioned it I I did want to jump
in and say something uh but I I lost
track I tend to do that I know well we
could we could yeah this there are a lot
of things that we've had to leave on the
table here tonight just and they asked
and the the interest of being respectful
and letting letting other people go on
but I would love to hear your
um your teachings on the death of Jesus
absolutely so one thing's for sure we're
definitely going to need a part two
eventually and I would love for us to to
uh go back you know all of us do
research look at what we can find and
touch base again and just this in the
future but very cool when it comes to
the crucifixion of Jesus actually it's a
lot of people misquote what the Quran
actually says
um and they just focus on the fact that
we don't believe he was killed or
crucified
um but what the Quran actually says word
for word is they they meaning the Romans
and Jews and people they did not kill
him nor did they crucify him but it was
made to appear that way so let me kind
of paint the picture because context is
very important you have Jesus right just
like Moses went to his people and it
literally split the sea for them Jesus
came he healed he's like you're blind
let me heal you you have leprosy let me
heal you this water I will walk on it
this water I will turn into wine there's
no explanation other than this person is
a prophet of God and telling the truth
and we need to listen to them
they still did not listen though these
are clearly very disobedient and and you
know defiant people just like
unfortunately the children of Israel had
a history of being very defiant
um and I don't need to mention the the
numerous times where that's recorded in
the Quran and in the Old Testament so
these people very clearly knew he was a
prophet but still wanted to kill him
they still wanted to go out of their way
and get rid of him so God you can maybe
look at it as their punishment let them
think that they succeeded in it because
Allah God leaves astray those who don't
want to be guarded he gives them the
message they reject it enough times God
said okay fine you want to be you want
to be left to straight go go astray so
they thought he was crucified
um but he wasn't and what happened is
very actually interesting I'll send you
guys a video that highlights this but in
Psalm 91 it speaks about Jesus and this
is confirming the New Testament being
protected by God so his enemies will not
beat him and he will be raised up to
heaven by the Angels the angels will
take him up to heaven right this is a
prophecy about Jesus and what happened
in the kind of you know Christian
theology is that he was killed
so how was he protected and taken up by
Angels if he ended up being killed that
doesn't add up the Quran came down and
said that the Angels took Jesus up peace
and blessings be upon him and protected
him so that he can come back which we
believe he's going to come back as well
for the second coming and kill the
Antichrist and all of that
so
very interesting because now you're
going to be saying whoa whoa whoa whoa
Romi relax the heck's wrong with you
you're crazy you're so ahistorical I
want to slap you but hear me out hear me
out the Quran says that it was made to
appear that way so what the people think
at the back then is that Jesus was
crucified so that is without a doubt
what they are going to say
but I will mention is it completely 100
a historical
to say that there were people that
believed he was not crucified that's not
true there was a second century Church
Father named bacilities
who people said that he claimed to have
a secret tradition he believed
and this is written in the book of
heresies um by um I forget who wrote it
that
Jesus was switched out on the cross with
Simon
and that and we believe that that Simon
not Simon but we believe that we're
Simon Simon Peter or the second Simon
like I'm I'm not sure which Simon says
okay not that it matters just in case
you know okay yeah
yeah so this iranius claimed that um
facilities claim that uh Simon to switch
out with uh with Jesus on the cross and
some people some Scholars say that what
happened is God replaced Jesus with one
of the disciples or with another person
and made him look like Jesus
so that people would think it was him
kind of other punishment
so there's actually a second century
person who believed who's a church
father who believed that Jesus was not
crucified and you have people like the
abianites and and I think the
monarchites or something like that who
believe that Jesus was not God but a
prophet and a messenger like Muslims
believe so all I'm going to say is that
judeo-christian history including the
time of Jesus is not something that is
certain or factual Simon of Cyrene um
the Warner says thank you brother
but um
so all I'm trying to say is that it is
not something that is clear-cut
especially historically
um and it is definitely something to be
investigated and does not invalidate the
Quran kind of based on what is said uh
does that make sense I know I said a lot
do you have any uh any questions about
that
that makes sense I mean it's definitely
like that that's probably the biggest
difference in the religions no yeah no
no so so wait wait I want to recap and
make sure I understand what you're
saying okay so my story is they put
Jesus up on the cross
the disciples who were not in hiding at
that point
um including his mother and Mary
Magdalene they were they and and many
others were there watched him die yeah
buried him in the tomb which they didn't
always give that that give that even
much courtesy to people that were
crucified but they did they let him be
buried in a tomb three days later
Mary Magdalene was the first one to see
him she came he came out and he was like
Hey I'm not dead hey you know God
brought me back to life and I'm
resurrected and which is an example of
what will happen to all of us if we if
we you know believe
and we you know succumb to God's will
and that then then there were hundreds
and hundreds of eyewitnesses to his
resurrection and the story spread like
wildfire after that and it was already a
fire and it went nuts okay that's my
story yours what I'm hearing is they
switched him out
they put somebody else on one of the
Apostles and the people that were there
witnessing Jesus's crucifixion
actually were tricked by God because God
made him this other person look like
Jesus
and then three days later Jesus just
like popped out from behind a tree and
was like you know like what happened
like I'm exaggerating I'm making light
of it but you know it it doesn't like
the part that God why would God trick
someone into that's it's over
complicating the story it's it seems
than what it you know my story is hard
enough to believe so and just just to
make sure we're on the same page before
Romney carries on the theological I
guess significance of the biblical
narrative is that this is the original
sin yes
mm-hmm that he he that he dies in order
that all of our sins might be forgiven
yes
to cleanse all of his followers of sin
it's not like the most important part of
the whole religion
it's like the base of it I mean no Jesus
dying on the cross so like that's a
massive difference like right in the
religions like yeah it's a big deal so I
just wanted to outline that to the
viewers too because people are like
where you guys going with this this is
the main theological significance of the
crucifixion that they believe yeah 100
so when this is why well first I want to
mention we don't believe Jesus came back
three days later we don't believe he he
appeared ever
um you know since then we do believe in
the second coming and the Antichrist and
all that obviously that hasn't happened
yet but we do believe that will happen
um the reason I mentioned the condyla
context is because it obviously it
sounds bad if God like just tricks
people
um but like I mentioned God is not just
tricking innocent people this is he's he
sent them a messenger who from our
perspective spoke as a baby healed the
Blind and the lepers walked on on Waters
recorded in the Bible
um you know did all these Miracles and
they still rejected him so God let them
go further into misguidance
um that's basically it but at the same
time you still have remnants in even
what we have today in the Bible of Jesus
and like for example Psalm 91 like I
mentioned saying that basically he will
not be crucified for lack of a better
term you still have Jesus himself kind
of
uh saying that there's one God and not
claiming to be God and all of that stuff
um but I I do I want to ask you a
question now
um you mentioned there are hundreds of
eyewitnesses now my question is were
there hundreds of reports or were were
there basically was there one report
that mentioned hundreds of eyewitnesses
there there were many reports I can't
give you a number I can come back on our
next talk and give you and give you more
actual I I'll give you more I'll do more
research and give some more data
from um you know the theologians and
historians who have studied this for
2000 years now and I'll be happy to but
you know go back to you know when he
from when he was arrested
and he he went through you know a full
day of torture and lashings and carrying
across through this town
um before he was ultimately hung on the
cross
and you know so for me to so whether or
not you someone would believe that he he
resurrected there really is very little
historical dispute that he went through
that process and he suffered
tremendously
um you know the thorn the crown of
thorns the lashings with the the whip
that had you know fragments of bone and
nail
but you know woven into it that his back
was raw and he many people died just
from the beating he took before he even
got up on the cross so there's a lot
there is eyewitness and historical
documentation around that
mostly from Apostles and theologians but
also from some uh there was a guy named
Josephus who was like a historian at the
time who was not a religious figure and
he mostly reported on political stuff
and um you know he he talks about Jesus
a little bit in there so there's so much
there that says that it was him and it
did happen and I I for me it's a it's a
bigger leap that God would try to
further fool the people that were doing
that to him because I think what
happened after that
is many of those people came to repent
and turn to God after the resurrection
after Jesus's death and at the
resurrection because they said now
they're like oh my god what have I done
and I think that that is more powerful
for them
so I and and I'm just not sure what the
motivation is for changing that story
other than to
undermine
yeah what if it wasn't changing the
story but actually clarifying a
misunderstanding if it was that no
that's a good point uh and it but but it
doesn't it feels like it's unclarifying
it and I feel it feels muddier than than
the original story yeah so I have I have
a question if you if you were loud I
mean because I see you going in but I
see you personally you but I have a
genuine question I've been holding it
for a long time it's burning me of this
side
you said that you you give the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him his
credibility that he was a prophet and
you you would do the same for Moses
David and all the rest of the prophets
that we have encountered yeah I'll stand
by that Okay so
when these prophets came would you also
agree that they came with the same
message
um I don't know
I I don't know the answer to that
because I don't know all of them again
and I know Jesus didn't talk about you
know the the scientific stuff that
Muhammad did so yeah they came with they
came with some of the same messaging and
some of it is is all you know it's all
over the place right or different
traditional and then again we're not
that's called as weird oh no I'm
fascinated
right yeah so if if all these prophets
are talking about God
and they're trying to remind Humanity
about God they have this message okay
the first prophet that comes into the
picture
they bring the message
okay it's fresh
everyone's hearing it everyone knows
about it once this Prophet is gone
why would another Prophet come into the
picture if the message was already
delivered
would it be because it was also we're
obstinate and we're ridiculous and we
need to be hit over the head a few more
times exactly exactly we have an ego and
our ego gets in the way we mess things
up it's just the way we are as humans so
because of this
God sends another prophet
and then the same thing happens again
right it's kind of like that game that
we used to play as kids I don't know if
you guys played this it was a telephone
game yes well like you would you would
tell someone something in their ear and
they tell it like in a circle and then
as is coming back like you you see if
it's the same thing you said in that
area so it's like God's been trying to
do this with all of humanity and each
time that we mess things up he brings
another Prophet with the same thing
trying to bring us back to him
no
if
Jesus because we finally came and he had
the original message
and then now he's not here let's see
okay let's see if figuratively speaking
he was crucified yeah so let's say he
was crucified
and even though he was crucified he
still left his message
he still left a message
he would it not then be pretty much
clarified that that message was also
altered by us which is why the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him came into the
picture and now after the prophet
Muhammad there has been no other Prophet
that has come down with this message
because God says in the Quran that this
is the message today I've completed my
favor upon you and I've given you the
entire message like I've completed it
it's done and it's going to be preserved
and therefore
today we have the Quran has not been
has not been altered whatsoever and you
have not had another Prophet come down
to basically spread the same message
bring people back to the same thing so
that's where it just brings a genuine
question like
okay well
then what's what's the truth here
I was going to ask that same question
why there hasn't been a prophet since
when the other prophets were coming
along did they say that there would be
more messages or each time was it
considered to be the last time God was
sending someone down
it's supposed to be the best time every
single time was supposed to be the last
time
well do we know that
Jesus said he was coming back yeah I I
would I would disagree a little bit um
because I I would say the children of
Israel actually like God had kind of a
Sunnah like a way with them where every
time a prophet would you know be killed
or would die he would send another one
and even at the time of the Prophet
peace be upon him the the Jews were were
basically telling the the Arabs the
people
um before the prophet Muhammad came out
as a prophet that you know they the Jews
used to tell them wait for us um uh when
we get our profit just wait for our
Prophet to come then you guys are gonna
see we're gonna you know dominate we're
gonna be on top and then when the
prophet Muhammad came and fulfilled the
criteria of the The Profit they're
waiting for
um but he turned out to be an Arab
instead of a Jew
um some of them rejected him because of
that reason uh so the prophet Muhammad
peace upon Him is the only one who
explicitly said I am the last and final
prophet of God even Jesus peace be upon
if you take the Bible to be something
that is is accurate and what he said he
said that I have many things to say unto
you
um but basically I cannot not do so now
so when the spirit of truth comes so on
and so forth he says like basis the
spirit of truth will come unto you and
he will basically you know
um tell you the truth and so on and so
forth and say things that I cannot say
um there are other instances in the Old
Testament that predict a a prophet who
will be a warrior of God who will go out
to the Gentiles and will basically
preach what God and this is um Isaiah 42
I believe
um you know the preach the word of God
he will make Mount Sila Singh Mount
sylla is a mountain I think in Medina or
in Mecca somewhere in that region and
the prophet peace be upon Him is the
only man ever recorded throughout
history
where when he walked into Medina the
people were on the mountain tops singing
for him enchanting and cheering for him
when he when he walked in so
yeah you want to say something well yeah
I
I just don't see how these two things
have to be mutually exclusive in the
sense that
Jesus
I do believe is God
one and the same with God
I also can believe that Muhammad is a
prophet
I see so and and I don't see why I can't
believe
both that Jesus as God would send
another Prophet because if that is the
case and they're looking down on us and
saying they can see the turmoil yeah I
mean we're clearly
falling further and further from God as
a human race yeah
um I can see him sending Muhammad and I
and I and I I'm cool with Muhammad's
what I know so far of Muhammad's message
and I think it's great and I think it
aligns in so many ways so I don't know
that it I don't know that it needs to be
one or the other and I do believe that
God speaks to us comes to us where we
are and maybe he's speaking to you in a
way that works better for you and works
better for me and I think it's all cool
maybe that maybe I'm just
oversimplifying it I mean let me ask you
a question would Jesus send a prophet
that says that Jesus is not God
yeah
yeah
um maybe
um maybe Jesus sent the prophet and
maybe the prophet got the message wrong
I don't know you know this it's a good
question and it needs it requires a lot
more research to find out what profits
messages directly from God though
or am I wrong yes but they're still
people
right you know I mean if if God gave you
a revelation uh saying you know worship
one God alone and and it's not Jesus do
you think that you could mess that up
if God came to me personally yeah if God
gave you a revelation and it was like
you know Jesus is not God
um and that was a revelation do you
think that would be something that you
would oh I'm a human and kind of slip up
well I think if God spoke to me directly
I would listen and you know I think that
that's a that I'd like to think that I
would be smart enough to pay attention
to that and know that it was real
um
is that not the first commandment in
Christianity
well the first are do we not all follow
the same Ten Commandments no well I mean
it's not not necessarily we it's it's
not that we don't follow it necessarily
it's just we don't have a concept of the
Ten Commandments we just have like like
sins and but we agree as far as I know
with my knowledge and Ten Commandments
that those things are sins like you know
coveting your neighbor's wife and and
taking
um other gods and so on and so forth
yeah they're pretty good they're pretty
good roles yeah 100 yeah
um yeah and honoring God is an honoring
mother in the my your mother and your
father and all the things
um but I I just with what I've learned
I'm so convinced that Jesus was
crucified
and that he could not have survived
and that he did fulfill his promise of
coming back and in a way to show us that
we will all be resurrected and live in
the Heavenly Kingdom if we come to God
through him
so
yeah it does put a crack in what I said
earlier a big crack in what I said
earlier about Muhammad being a prophet
but I still do believe that he can he
could have come and put those messages
you know out into the world but
to what I would like to talk to Muslim
Scholars and find out what scrutiny the
Quran has been put under
because as we started in this
conversation a long time ago
um you talked about how the Quran is
meant to be memorized and I think a lot
of that is because back in the day as
the fort up to you know when Jesus was
around when Muhammad was around
everything was taught orally you know it
wasn't easy we didn't have you know
printing presses and it wasn't easy to
get your hands on paper so it was very
important to learn stories and phrases
orally
um
but
as you've told as you've taught me they
you know Muhammad didn't read or write
so he then had people reading and
writing which is the same criticism that
we get
about Jesus how do we know that what
these guys wrote down is true how do we
know what he said and what they're
saying he said
and you know what scrutiny has the Quran
been put under from historians and
archaeologist to to say that that's all
accurate and this part about Jesus is
accurate because I I'm really convinced
that it really happened the way I
thought it does yeah hold on so
this is why I had the question because
we were talking about this right and we
said how the Quran is um it's made very
simple very easy to memorize
my question to you have you ever heard a
recitation of the Quran
no I have not okay beautiful there's
this one Surah which means chapter it's
the first chapter of the Quran it's
called Suraj
every single Muslim knows this why
because we recite this
every single day five times a day it's
the main prayer for guidance
Romney please bro please
show them Surah Al Fatiha bro bro more
than five times a day does that address
my does that address my question though
about I think I think it'll address I
think it'll address a lot of questions
to where to who wrote it down who wrote
it down yeah so it definitely question
you know yeah the reason okay before
Romy goes the reason I'm I'm like even
bringing this up is because you say that
like
perhaps there's a suspicion that maybe
these other the companions of the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessing be
upon them is that they may have got it
wrong just like maybe the disciples may
have gotten right as well right so
that's a genuine concern that's genuine
you know question but then again it goes
back to the the Quran being very simple
and very easy to
memorize and it just it hits differently
even people who don't understand the
language like I'm genuinely I still
don't understand the language myself I'm
Puerto Rican I speak Spanish I don't
speak every but it's something different
and I'm gonna let Rami go because it's
again like when it's something like this
like this
there's just no way and there's no way
that someone would just
completely get something wrong here but
go ahead mom please please yeah so I do
want to answer your question head on
because it is a great question and it's
something that I've looked into I'd say
not definitely on a scholarly level
because I'm not a scholar but I think in
depth enough to give a reasonable answer
so when it comes to the quran's
preservation and something like you know
like the Bible's preservation I wouldn't
even compare the Quran to the Bible in
that way and there's a reason for that
I'll discuss the after but I first want
to focus on the Quran the Quran
was delivered to the prophet peace be
upon him um from God through the angel
Gabriel as we all know over 23 years and
every time you know maybe something
would happen sometimes God would reveal
Revelation in regards to a certain
situation so we have context to know
when these verses were applied when they
were set down so on and so forth and
this happened over 23 years every time
Revelation would come down the prophet
peace be upon would have two companions
who could read and write write the what
was revealed down on whatever they had
and they would read it back to the
prophet peace be upon him and make sure
it's correct and they would go and they
would tell the people and and teach the
people and um they would memorize that
as well and then over the 23 years they
compiled the Quran
part of me you had people like the
cousin of the Prophet who may God be
pleased with them who had basically like
91 out of 113 chapters of the Quran to
himself in his own book he memorized the
whole thing but he had it written down
in his own book just just for him and
others had other parts here and there at
the time of Abu Bakr who is the best
friend of the Prophet for his whole life
right this is when Abu Bakr came into
leadership he literally I'm talking like
maybe less than 10 years after the
prophet passed away had people a one one
specific companion who's very
knowledgeable
um basically make the book into one
compiled book so instead of being on
different manuscripts here and there he
went to the people who memorized it and
they were very specific very very
specific qualifications that basically
it has to be memorized by two people
with very strong memory and restoration
and all that
um and they there cannot be any uh
confliction with like basically anyone
um with that verse and he would collect
it and then later this was done
basically again in the time of man and I
can discuss that but it's a little bit
longer of a story so for the sake of it
I think that clears it up so you have
it's pretty tight it's a pretty tight
timeline and a pretty tight set of rules
it sounds like and and what's very
important for Muslims and this gets to
what I do compare the Bible to which is
the Hadith the narrations of the Prophet
we have sayings of the Prophet peace be
upon himself from his mouth what he said
and what he did delivered to us from his
companions in what we call chains of
narration so it would literally be like
Rami told on hill on Hill told fayad
fire told sunny sunny told his mom that
um you know we're we're all very happy
to be here today that's what Rami said
you know and we know that I'm a good you
know I have a good memory I'm a good
transmitter so was Angel Souls fayad all
these people are trustworthy reliable we
have names of people going back to the
prophet peace upon himself with he said
this and so on and so forth when you
look at something like the Bible
obviously it's not to be disrespectful
and I don't mean to offend anybody but
when you look at the Bible mark Matthew
Luke and John as the gospels were just
kind of conveniently named The Gospel
According to Mark Matthew Luke and John
no they weren't they were rules
they I mean if you ask any new testament
scholar those gospels were written
anonymously
like Mark Matthew Luke and John were
written anonymously we don't know who
actually authored those those Gospels
um we actually do Luke was a Luke was a
follower of um Paul and he was a doctor
and a scholar in his own right and he
learned everything he he wrote from Paul
uh Matthew it the Book of Matthew was
very clearly
um written by him and it was slanted
towards his uh his personal bend on
understanding you know reconciling
Christianity and Judaism and so so I'm
not sure where that
um assertion comes from because because
they were they the whole reason they are
they are considered the purest and
um most
reliable sources of what happened is
because they were written by either
Apostles or the Apostle followers of
Apostles so it was two and two two
written by Apostles two written by their
their their students
and they and they have to have very
specific uh the church early on set very
specific rules for what and those are
the only four books in the whole Bible
that met that criteria
yeah so I'm I'm not trying to say that
like Matthew didn't have the lean of
Matthew or it didn't like for example
like initially start with Matthew or his
perspective
um although there are you know um New
Testament Scholars that say that like
Mark Matthew Luke had the same Source
material to begin with right what I'm
trying to say is that who put pen to
paper for the gospel of Matthew was not
Matthew himself so you know you can no
no I know that you're trying to say and
I'm and I'm I I where did where's that
coming from and I'd like to maybe we
should look more into that more because
it's not at all what I've it's not at
all what I've been taught and
um
and I I I don't think it's accurate yeah
and I mean there's there's you know no
no problem in disagreeing New Testament
Scholars disagree as well um what I'm
giving is one New Testament scholar or
one one scholarly opinion which is that
we don't know the authors
um and you'll find this basically all
over you know Chris uh sorry New
Testament scholarship
um let me mention something a little
more definitive most of the New
Testament manuscripts we have actually
come from I think the 7th Century or
maybe even the ninth but it came at
least 800 years or like most of the
manuscripts are from at least 800 years
after Jesus peace be upon him so for us
to look at these manuscripts and try and
derive an original or say that we can
say these are the original
um is not possible which is why New
Testament Scholars like bar Ehrman
um in his one of his debates with
another New Testament scholar they both
agreed to this by the way he said that
new testament Scholars stop using the
word The Originals they stopped using
the term because they know there's no
such thing and that we're not going to
find it at this pace because even with
like yeah we have early second century
manuscripts but they're smaller than a
credit card
um and they don't have too too much on
it mostly manuscripts and all that come
from like hundreds of years after Jesus
we don't know how many Scrabble errors
um you know occurred or how many
intentional changes occurred from the
time of Jesus peace be upon him to those
manuscripts and the reason this is so
important is because even in the current
Bible we have today we will find very
clear I would say you know distinctions
or contradictions that you can't really
reconcile
um for example James was teaching people
to uphold the law while Paul was going
to the Gentiles saying you don't have to
worry about you know circumcising your
children all this you don't need to
worry about the law just believe Jesus
died for your sins but that's people
that's people not Jesus but I can
address all of this because I've been
reading about all this and hearing all
of these exact arguments and um
and and and scholarly opinions that
address them and explain them actually
pretty well and I would I want to we can
you can keep talking now but I'm gonna
stick a pen in it for myself and on our
next call I totally want to dig into
this more because I I know where to find
the answers at least even if I don't
know them by heart absolutely and I
respect that very very much I respect
that very much one of the things Muslims
are taught is that when you don't know
and this goes you know more so for me
finding on he'll be online when we don't
know something we have to say I don't
know and just you know not say anything
yeah because I know there's a lot of
people Muslim Anonymous that would sit
here and try and make something up to
sound good and it's obviously that's not
something that is commendable but uh you
guys very much argumentable my eyes I
appreciate you guys coming on so much
this has been such a beautiful
discussion and I I really hope that we
can continue this on or off stream
really does not matter to me we have to
talk more because I love your
perspectives and I love everything I'm
learning from you and I love that you're
driving me to you know I'm driving
myself to learn more but you're driving
me even more and hitting the gas for me
and I just love it and I think that I
want to go back to the same thing that
are what we have in common whether or
not we ever agree on you know uh
if Jesus was crucified like I don't care
it doesn't matter I care about it but I
don't care if we agree so super Clarity
um I I just think that the fact that
we're having these conversations and
showing how much we have in common is
what really matters and I and I think we
should I I hope that more Christians and
Muslims will sit down together and have
conversations that end in wow you know
we're all on the same team here at the
end in the end yeah 100 and very very
beautifully said Allah tells us in the
Quran to come to terms and agreements
and find similarities with the people of
the book that we believe in one God
alone and I think that is definitely a
very beautiful uh place to start and end
off with um do either of you have any
questions for us before we end the the
live stream
I mean I have some questions that I
wrote down I didn't know if I should do
sure Let's do let's do a quick fire Bros
I feel like I feel like Sonny didn't
even get the Limelight yeah well my
mom's more um she knows more about you
know the actual model so it makes sense
that she would be more you know involved
but I mean I I don't know I kind of have
some weird questions so like who who did
people pray to
before BC or what is the Quran talk
about because if this religion is only 2
000 years old and it it truly is you
know the truth and stuff then like
there's there's been people for
thousands and thousands of years before
that who who were they were they praying
to and what did they look up to yeah so
you can actually see all throughout
history so if you guys want to take the
the mic you can jump in fighter on Hill
I just wanted to say um you're probably
gonna go in and say it's not 2 000 years
ago
oh what's not two thousand years ago
like Islam is not like you know 600
years ago or so yeah that's what I mean
yeah yeah 100 so Islam just means
submission to God you'll find throughout
many Traditions especially like when you
look at Judaism
um they yeah they don't use the word
Allah it's a different language but they
they'll say Elohim Yahweh and so they
won't say the good name of God they
think it's too holy to say but what they
describe is what who we believe to be
Allah God you know one Creator
um who is independent self-sufficient
created everything that exists is all
knowledgeable all the best attributes
belong to him so on and so forth
um and he knows everything and all of
that you'll find that the people you
have people who worship like fire and
these Pagan things but in terms of
actually worshiping God Islam has always
been there in terms of worshiping one
God with the characteristics I described
it was their um sense of Judaism or
sorry there since the time of Adam
before Judaism
um many different I'm forgetting the the
the people that you know we know worship
on God I don't think it's zoroastrians
um I think it's a different thing but
basically you'll find throughout history
people worship on God Alone Allah did
not was not invented with Islam you know
Allah even the Arabs at the time of the
Prophet before Islam came they believed
in Allah yeah they worshiped Idols but
they believed that those Idols were a
way to get to Allah
and that's one of the things the prophet
peace upon it came to to denounce so I
hope that's clear that islamedics are
1400 years ago there's one God where
they worshiped throughout all of history
that humans have an inclination to
worship
and to enter the to answer that bro we
everything that's created so every
created thing is actually born in a
state of submission it's created in the
state of submission to the Creator
itself
um you can notice this from the animals
and just everything if you actually just
pay attention and look at what God has
created in this world now we as humans
we we have this innate desire to worship
something right now if we do not worship
God we worship maybe money maybe it
could be women maybe it could be men it
could be a job maybe it could be I don't
know something some artists or something
exactly exactly so the point is that
throughout history people have this and
they desire to worship something so if
they're not worshiping God then they're
going to worship something else and when
you see all these different their Idols
right like in Hinduism you have Idols in
uh Roman mythology and Greek mythology
this you have the God of War you have
the like Zeus you have all this stuff
with Greek and Rome it's actually the
same thing just different names
exactly exactly exactly and we had this
brother on here on the podcast
um may God bless him because he's just
Powerhouse like he has so much knowledge
and so much wisdom but he was saying how
like
what ends up happening when you when
someone says okay the God of War
right
you can't have the God of War without
God itself because it's basically like
if if I give you two things if I tell
you to think about a mountain
you can think about a month and you've
probably seen a mountain maybe in a
picture or in real life you've heard
about it it's around yeah if I tell you
to think about gold you're probably
single you probably felt gold you talked
about it at some points you can
understand what gold is but if I tell
you imagine a gold Mountain
you've never seen a gold Mountain it's
it for as much as we know it does not
exist so because of this it's like you'd
have to like bring the two ideas the
idea of the mountain and the idea of the
goal together to create a gold Mountain
so when we say the God of War may God
forgive us for this you're bringing the
idea of God and the idea of war and then
linking it together which is a clear
error because you're you're attributing
this thing as like this is being like
this is one God of this and you have
another God of this so again it just
goes to show that
we want to worship something and you see
that throughout history
so I hope that kind of just has honestly
incredible it's definitely the truth
because
before I made any money or anything you
know you think like once I hit a hundred
thousand dollars that's all that's all
you need and it is all just Idols at the
end of the day because you hit it and it
doesn't mean anything even like a
hundred thousand Subs like for the
longest time in my head it's like a
YouTube plaque is like the Holy Grail
like I did it right there yeah and then
I I thought that was your fuse box I'm
so sorry
oh this is well I don't know if you can
see it but this is this is from my
channel my other YouTube channel and I
have like closing in on 300 000
subscribers and it's the same thing but
like it doesn't mean anything at the end
of the day yeah it's nice to have and it
does mean it does mean something but it
means something in the sense that like
we have to remember
um today I do the verse of the day uh on
this on this Bible app and it talked
about everything we accomplish
isn't our accomplishment it's God's
accomplishment so if through your other
channel you got that award but you were
able to do the work could do God's work
through that and spread the word that
you're trying to spread then it is it is
worthwhile but it again it isn't it
isn't everything to hang your hat on so
I don't I I don't think we should fully
diminish accomplishments either oh no of
course
I'm just saying that I forget this was
um like Witcher which his son Sony was
saying is that he wanted to get that
hundred thousand and it's like okay well
once you get it it's um it's an empty
feeling and that's the Mind our mind
makes it out to be like ah once we get
this thing then we'll be good once we
get that thing then we'll be good but
it's never the case and the only case
where we actually feel the peace
is when we do the main thing that we
were actually created for which was
to worship God
yeah so it just all comes back
yeah no yeah like like I was gonna say I
mean I felt excited for maybe like like
30 seconds like I'm not even joking it
gets old so quick it really is so empty
and a lot of people do the same thing
with money everything and it's it's just
never ending so think of it this way
when you're having a bad day or bad when
I'm having a bad day or a bad moment
if I talk to God
it it it it just it helps to fill me
with peace and Trust
that it's going to work if I'm having
that same bad moment and I think about
that time I got a hundred thousand Subs
cribed to do the same thing like it
doesn't like God is so consistent
consistent and and pure and and is
always it always is it has the retail
therapy effect always
you know where you know those other
things you can revisit them and go Ah
that's nice but it's not really going to
help you it's not going to be the light
in the dark in your life
yeah should I ask another question or do
you guys have to write yeah
are you all good I'm good I'm getting
thirsty and and hot and and you know
it's getting late but yeah I got a
little left in me
um so well I'll ask God for more
strength today you know
uh so I had a question I mean I kind of
want to just bring it up like about the
recent Balenciaga stuff that's going on
and where there's evil where it's it's
demonstrated right in front of your eyes
and they don't even try to hide it does
the Quran mention anything like that
about watching out for evil specifically
and not like strategies to like avoid it
but does it say anything about like the
strategies that these current people are
using to to push clear evil and stuff
that's clearly against uh the will of
God
um actually I'd say maybe surprisingly
to some people yes though there are
instances of that for example
um God would god mentioned Allah
mentioned in the Quran
um there's a few different examples the
people that you know cause corruption in
the earth and then when you go to them
and say you're causing corruption they
say that no we're just instilling peace
we're just instilling peace you know and
these people will come they'll be like
no we're just we're just fighting for
rights we're just fighting for basic
human rights well that's what they say
yeah they're really hiding something
demonic under the Skies of Human Rights
but Islam will say well you know your
rights who determines what a right is
you're just making it up and then saying
you're fighting for this thing you made
up all while hiding this demonic thing
Allah also mentions in the Quran people
who would be punished and why are they
punished because they put themselves
into bad predicaments you know people
like I'm guys like I'm gonna go preach
the message outside of a nightclub it's
like bro like you're literally one step
away from being inside this demonic Hall
and this is where you want to go preach
the message like yeah they need it but
is that the circumstance you as a person
should be putting yourself in not
necessarily I would say same thing with
you know maybe going to some of these
fashion conventions or to some of these
concerts and I know you had a very
specific opinion on concert sunny and I
love that take
um for those who don't know sunny I
believe is against concerts because it's
cringe to go just jump Bob your head up
and down like a loser uh it's it's
really cringe honestly it's just a waste
of time
um and there are probably some I'm not
remembering currently but it's literally
all over the Quran but the best summary
to make as fast as possible is anything
that God tells us is good
um is something that's beneficial to us
and will be good for us and we should
enjoy those things anything that is
Haram that is evil that is wrong we
should avoid it and and as for the
measures we should take to avoid it
um the best best measure is prevention
completely
complete prevention that's why people
will see Islam as strict but it's not
really strict in in all honesty it's
just we're so Loose as a society we
don't care what we do uh you can
literally the government will let you
drink till you kill yourself and it
doesn't really matter to them Islam will
say no anything that intoxicates you in
large amounts you cannot even have a
little bit of it so wow that's it's
really interesting you say that point
because I've kind of felt the same way
where they do a lot of this stuff with
the Trojan Horse so they'll say it's
just for acceptance It's just for mental
health and that's why they're giving
hormones to kids that's that the excuses
they use is a pretty much Perfect
Analogy of what you just said yeah
definitely and when you're young and
even when you're older you know you
could be fooled by causes and they and
and because they are due like perfect
they come in a trojan horse and so I
think the way to avoid that and I may
just be repeating what you just said
around me is just stay true to God and
then you don't you don't put yourself on
a path path where you can come into
contact with a trojan horse at all
avoidance and you know it's like what do
I say nothing every every mother says
this nothing good happens after nine
o'clock out you know so stay in the
house that you know come home uh and and
that's kind of a a simplistic way of of
you know staying out of trouble
and staying away from those evil things
but the Balenciaga thing I think was
just so
so outrageously atrocious you couldn't
even make it up the level of detail they
went to to promote child pornography and
that's just like the most clear evil
that there is so it's so it's just crazy
that that's like one of the biggest
fashion companies that's what their real
motives are like I still can't believe
that that's that was a real a real story
that wasn't just a scene in a in a in a
weird movie yeah but the thing is man
this is we shouldn't even be surprised
about this
you know and we we shouldn't even look
to see uh or what what is said in
religions about these things I mean we
just need to use our clear judgment our
own eyes like we can see these things in
front of our eyes when I was younger I'm
not that old by the way let me say that
yeah
I appreciate that I appreciate it when I
was younger
I would go to these festivals
I would go to these things like EDC you
know what EDC is right yep bro I went to
EDC and let me tell you something
everyone there is on drugs either
they're on drugs or they're drinking and
bro that I was at this one Stadium where
it's like okay the music was nice at the
time but as will I jump in as we're
dancing everyone's like everyone looks
like NPC characters yeah they're Bots
bro everyone's like
jumping like this I'm like what the hell
is wrong with these people yeah and as
bro as this is happening there's random
things that are popping over on the
stage people aren't like they're not
catching on to it because they're so far
gone something else is controlling them
at that point in time whether they're
drinking or whether on a substance
something else is controlling them when
I was there on this stage clear as night
and day bro
do you know what bafflement is
have you ever heard of bafflement no
Baphomet write that down do your
research on that that is
I think it's some kind of like demon or
something that these people worship
they were showing Baphomet just right on
the stage like this and I'm literally
like I stopped dancing
and I'm looking at this thing and I'm
just looking around to see if anyone
else is like catching this no one else
was catching it because again everyone's
like off somewhere else and from that
moment in time I was like whoa there's
something really messed up happening
here and I started doing my own research
turns out that that's not the first
thing and it keeps going deeper and
deeper and deeper and it's not just a
festival bro it's everywhere in the
world so it's like the Balenciaga stuff
it's like Nike has something at one
point like bro and no matter where you
go like it's these are signs that show
us that we are in the end of times or we
are nearing the end of times so it's
again like we don't we don't need
something or someone to tell us this
it's just we just look for ourselves and
we can see it a lot of times
oh I was just going to wrap it up uh his
point with a lot of people ask these
questions like you see little now sex
giving say no lap dance is it really
that obvious isn't that too like do you
guys really believe in Satan in this and
one of the tricks or one of the main
ideas or intentions of the devil is to
convince the world that he doesn't exist
so in a way it really has to be kind of
out in plain sight
um that's a really good point
because that's been an episode we made
about the metaverse that they really
need that type of consent like if you
look at demonic rituals and how they
kind of do what they do we don't want to
go too much you guys can do your own
research but when you do it they need
that consent from people they can't do
it behind people's backs
wow yeah that's really interesting
because I used to look at that stuff as
kind of just like uh whatever
like it's just them their culture not
their culture but I wouldn't look at it
as as big of a deal and then I'd see
older people getting really mad at that
stuff and I kind of didn't understand
why they got so mad and then now when
you look deeper and you're like wow it's
it's it's not just like coincidence that
he's dancing on the devil like there's
true evil behind that stuff and it
really does change your whole
perspective on it
yeah yeah we got a lot of work to do we
have to fish we have to fish and find
more people and you keep fishing let's
all go fishing I don't care I'm not
kidding we're gonna take the balance we
can actually go fishing in real life too
in real life I get sad I feel bad for
the fish even though I eat them I'm a
hypocrite oh we gotta listen out and
next stream insha Allah God willing we
can talk about Christmas too because I
want to know your take on Christmas you
know Santa Claus and all this even as a
kid I would always wonder I was like my
parents and like you know everything I
was taught about Islam we learned that
you know Allah God knows all you do if
you're good or you're bad if you're a
good boy or a naughty boy whatever they
make Santa you know Santa Claus be and
they're like you know we have to pray to
Allah and then Allah will give us what
we want and then when I go to school
they're telling us this is what we got
to do with Santa Claus we gotta write
letters to Santa which is kind of like a
Dua but you know it's not right so
you're making a prayer to something that
doesn't even exist I'm sure no kid
growing up really believed in Santa
closed captioning not available
[Music]
and doesn't that be tragic if you ask me
that would be tragic
you know yes I I love what you just said
um I want to go back to fayad what the
Santa Claus thing and I I would like to
have an entire conversation about that
as well because I want to hear your
thoughts on it
um
I
I don't know back in biblical times you
know year 2000 and the year you know 600
what children's bedtime stories looked
like was it just teaching children you
know was it just bedtime prayers was was
it nothing was it were there fictional
characters that were used you know to to
keep children's imaginations going and
just for fun and and I'm sure you know I
like to think there were there was
fiction and you know to me that's what
Santa Claus is I think it's I think it's
a fun thing to do with your kids and
play you know have an imaginary uh
friend in the North Pole that you
eventually grow up and learn doesn't
exist
um and I don't know that I see the harm
in it but I wanna I don't want to get
into it too much right now because I do
want to hear your perspective on that
and my my perspective is certainly very
American
um uh and not that Santa Claus is a
uniquely American thing but my my I'm
I'm American Santa who's super
materialistic
I think I think given that it's it's the
holiday season December 25th is coming
up I think we can definitely do uh an
episode on Christmas sometime we can
talk about that
um who's like an Islamic scholar and as
the chef I was like what are your
thoughts on Santa Claus don't you find
it crazy that it people are basically
committing idolatry they're asking you
know Santa Claus for all this and
they're like Santa he was like Santa is
just Satan rearranged and he's like the
goal of Satan is always to misguide the
people and get them to prostrate to
something that isn't God
and I'll never forget them all right
Santa means Saint
I mean yeah Nicholas
but you know you know what I mean and
that's one um if Sunny you have any
other questions that you want us to just
rapid
fires now you can talk about it um I
think we can just save it for the next
time cool now before we wrap up the
stream we want to give you the full
Islam raw me bro listen
if you want to recite the Quran right so
in Islam I'm sure you know we recite
Quran you can find Quran recitations
anywhere the opening of the Quran is
called Surah Al Fatiha right this is
basically the opening the first chapter
or first Surah of the Quran
um Rami if you want you can recite it
now if you don't we can recite the next
you know stream as well whatever you're
good with he has the best uh recitation
voice out of all of us Allah Mubarak
that's why I I thought that on me I'd
love to hear it I have a question are
you going to recite it in English so
that we understand it or you can do it
I'm not being fresh I mean I just I
would love to get something from it you
know that that would help us understand
it a little more absolutely absolutely
so I actually have the Quran here so I
can't when it comes to reciting you
can't recite it in um in English because
there are specific rules to reciting it
in the Arabic language
um but there definitely is the
translation have you guys heard a
recitation of the Quran before
no haven't you guys have do you guys
have a coffee
not yet no inshallah we will send you
guys one we'll touch base afterwards and
send you one thank you thank you so I'll
recite it and I I listen
if I had hyped me up my station's not
that great you guys should hear Angela
Mubarak he has an amazing voice honestly
but there are reciters that have such
beautiful voices I want to send you
um uh Surah Maryam chapter about Mary
Mother Mary peace be upon him yes and um
the restitution there is is beautiful
and I honestly think it will resonate
with you guys so
I'm going to recite
um again the opening is to Allah
alhamdulillah
[Music]
foreign
I mean
and what that means
in the name of Allah in the name of God
the most gracious the most merciful
all praises to God the lord of the
worlds The Compassion the most
compassionate the most merciful Master
of the day of judgment you alone we
worship and you alone we ask for help
guide us along the straight path the
path of those who you have blessed not
the path of those who you are displeased
with nor those who want astray
we recite this alhamdulillah I mean amen
we recite this at least five times a day
um but it's it's it's one of the most
beautiful chapters in the Quran
um because the first half of it is
praising God the other half of it is
asking God to guide us and keep us on
the straight path
um so it does it does honestly wonders
for Muslims alhamdulillah
it's a really nice opening it really it
really is you know that says
you know I basically I heard when you
said in English like I trust in
everything I'm about to read here and I
trust that you will give me the strength
to you know live by it
100 right is that kind of all right nice
beautiful very beautiful all right thank
you thank you I have never heard that
before in person or online or maybe I
heard in a movie and I didn't know you
know what I was hearing so thank you for
sharing that of course of course you
guys are awesome
no no y'all were awesome listen honestly
again it's almost two and a half hours
now and it feels like it's only been a
few minutes like I don't know if they
kind of said it in the beginning but
when we started this YouTube channel
they they said something but in reality
like my thoughts when I started this
YouTube channel with them is I wanted to
share the conversations that we had with
other people because it's not very often
that you have these conversations and
and this right here this right here this
this is what it's all about this brings
me back to like the the first days that
we were making YouTube videos where it's
like this is why we started it's like
these conversations right here
to on point
beautiful yeah it was a good time really
good really good thank you fellas thank
you so much for so much of your time and
we'll be back with you soon what you
guys we'll let we'll you know have I'll
have my people talk to your people
coming on
um thank you for for holding it out this
long as well um it doesn't mean a lot
these are the conversations that matter
um with that being said on our end uh we
want to say Allah
that means um
may all basically may Allah may God give
us goodness in this life and in the
afterlife and protect us from the
punishment of the fire Allah I mean
um and with that being said
peace be with you
as well